sink fall
i
command you to become one
god damn it that's pretty close uh i if
that one's not working these brings over
here watch these ones i shall i shall
join you forever in all eternity you
shall be joined oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh
just it's good you just go inside each
other yeah oh that was a direct hit that
worked last time come on
oh no that's a bad thing that was my
fault that's my fault
why
aha
yeah the power of editing you did that
on the first try
unbelievable
that's right
oh that's pretty cool yeah that's a
great trick
have you guys been playing rings this
whole time mark did a magic for a lot of
things
come look i did a magic trick
i'm not joking
whoa
through the power of magic these two
rings are become one wow
and through the power of the same magic
but in backwards
[Laughter]
right i know you want to see me do it
again yeah i do yeah i do with one swift
toss of a ring
and no luck whatsoever
i
join you for eternity
[Music]
oh that's pretty that's pretty close i
hit the target that's pretty close yeah
yeah
i join you for eternity
i did it in one try the first time trust
me yeah yeah
you can't you can't do that you gotta
throw it up that does that violates the
entire spirit and also the in
okay mark you try it
what the hell kind of [ __ ] magic was
that i don't know i don't know i just
threw it this was my thing no wait stop
i'm the best at this
[Laughter]
the get out wow here some new sheriffs
in town
what why is my why is this invincible to
my magic what is this
what have you created
like what do you do oh hey that's pretty
cool
i'm part of it
guys i'm part of it
you just have been joined
oh god damn it wow
this was my thing at least you still
have the bags in the hole
yeah the best of the bags in the hole
that's true
don't try mark it's my thing what thing
nothing
lexian can you put in a robot voice as
we're doing this just like if you enjoy
this type of content
i did it
you would love distractible available
through the link in the description
below
that's very accurate
if you are enjoying this content then
you're sure to love distractible
move your spry fingers down to that
description and you'll find a link to
endless hours
this
i mean i need to do it like this
oh yeah that's the angle that's the
angle right there you want to hit him
with that yeah so far every ring is
joined if you can get that joint to join
the two other rings
one ring to bind them all
one ring i know what it means the l
didn't bring the
magic touch
oh that bag got in the way needs a
little of the old magic touch
magic torch
magic from midtown
oh
you're stronger than me
magic from dayton
oh i'd hit the ceiling magic from point
blank
oh
[Music]
hang on i got this
they're all connected in one way or
another two on this side not connected
to the other ones though oh you're right
they're all connected let's not look at
that anymore
all connected
yeah they're all connected
hey they got glow sticks in here why
don't we have glow sticks in the camper
all right i'll add glow sticks hell yeah
we're going to the photo i didn't know
we could make requests
uh i want a stretch armstrong
can i get one it'll
all right two of them you got it thank
you
and i want the one where he has the
special vest the hat yeah
oh of course you want the limited
edition i don't need that one i don't i
don't need it i'm okay
okay we can share when we can share that
we'll share we'll share
we'll see we're sharing great deal done
just ready up and it'll be there for you
okay thank you
okay if that's
[Applause]
get an average sanity below 25 percent
what if you need them
that means easy oh my god my ear oh my
god hey buddy thanks pal
all right well the old farmhouse
we always appreciate it i entirely
forgot what we were talking about before
i'm just going to
open the thing let's do this boys uh
yeah we just need uh repel the ghost
with a smudge stick while it's chasing
someone
don't you need like lighter and smudge
to do that
yeah that's annoying i could bring that
in and just like leave it in there so
that it's in the house ready to rip
that's true you get hunted you have it's
nice just press i think you press f to
light it but i wouldn't do it now but
yeah okay you got it here we go all
right
what's your name helen helen
radio
helen what hello
i was doing the thing where you breathe
it talk and i like breathed in such a
big glob of spit or something my my
throat was like nope all right well nope
nope don't do that i found it
found an axe axe has been found
that's great
oh you're getting caution lighter are
there checking the backyard i'm gonna
leave my emf reader here for now and i'm
gonna go get a photo camera
seeing nothing besides a cool scarecrow
in the
backyard ah
interesting
it doesn't look like anything's in the
backyard that i can see any sign of
bones anywhere in the house any nice
bones
no no bones for you
yeah where i'll gladly take it
just come over here it's in my pants
oh you've already picked it up great
please tell me that was someone taking a
picture
that was an exact picture oh thank god i
thought it was using a picture marketing
where are you at
lady
what was the full name helen what
helena bonham carter ah
okay
hey i found a cursed item
it's not in the game it's just an ugly
picture
yeah it's pretty close
it's a picture of me isn't it why is
this door freaking out
bob you seeing this
no it looks normal to me wade are uh
doors that freak out and constantly move
a ghost event
if there's a door that you opened it's
freaking out our door that opened itself
we opened it so probably not it's
probably just the
game freaking out
all right
if you say so
this guy you know bob i'm thinking that
we don't need him
i'm right here was that door hey oh wait
wait uh bob i don't think we need bob
yeah freezing temps right here my guys
in this hole he's right there he
probably heard you say that i heard you
mark i think you're right i don't think
we need wade yeah you're right
oh oh by the way spirit box doesn't work
when the lights are on dude to turn
lights off if you're gonna use spirit
box well you that sounds like a you
problem i don't have a spirit box what
do you want
he sounds like a detective from a 1950s
noir drama what do you want
ah what are you after yeah what do you
want see
i can still hear you guys that's good
where did you go huh helena
a dame wait did you find anything
upstairs
mark you were like on the stairs when
you started talking and it was
all right
these guys don't
i
appreciate
the bone was upstairs
uh i'm hearing a lot of wind up here
you guys hearing like a rhythmic almost
musical wind
it's hunting mark
what it's hunting why aren't you guys
telling me it's hunting wade said it's
hunting and then went quiet because he's
in the house what i don't hear
it's done yeah you guys were gonna let
me die
without even telling me right to the
left of where we were standing her face
in that laundry room it's the room to
the left
hello right where the freezing temps
were someone up here with me
are either of you upstairs at the moment
no no sir we're downstairs
[Music]
that's a bad sign uh yeah um okay where
was that
oh phone ring
go take a right
yeah yes yeah yeah i think you might
have bob where were you lead mark to
your corpse
hunting uh huh
it's in the it's in the living room mark
it seems to know where you are
yeah but it doesn't know what i mean why
don't be quiet it's leaving
it's going into the kitchen right now
it turned around
okay it's staying in the living room
it's singing i don't like it
it's not very good at singing okay
it's coming towards you mark oh it's
gone
it's gone
uh mark come outside whenever you can we
need to take all the sanity pills it's
like now
running running running running outside
running outside
running outside
running outside running outside running
oh there was a weird creaking behind me
wait there was a weird creaking behind
me
you'll feel a lot better no i don't know
guys i think you should come back inside
the house i think it's
we're on our way as soon as mark takes
i think the ghost got sick of it and
left
i don't think there's anything to be
afraid of
that's great right there yeah
just go hang out in the living room
that seems like a good place to have a
good time great i love living
i'm gonna put down a book
just find that
how can we help you
what do you want
wade i think you should put that
crucifix outside the house
[Music]
i'm starting to think it's safe uh-oh
we're friends you can trust me
yeah where are you
i'm right here
uh
i'm just kidding it's totally safe don't
worry guys you were kidding about it
being totally safe because that's what
you were saying before
no no i'm not serious about it if i was
just goofing around
okay so it's not safe or it's really
not safe okay so we're good
uh oh who turned on the light there must
be a friendly ghost helping you out
uh
not me though not me it's real cold in
here try wait wait wait where are you
need to grab another camera back in all
right cool he's lying to you mark he's
not coming back he's lying he's lying to
me
oh god no no no no
you're about to join the winning team
[Music]
[Music]
in your discord so everyone can hear you
am i not unmuted
you're not
hang on
i wait
we're hugging you
[Music]
all right well we're doing great we're
making some serious progress i think
i've lost five grand today so we're
definitely earning some sweet cash i
blame uh
myself for our failure on that level i
gotta be honest as you should as you
should as you should um wait how's your
money doing
i'm spending a lot i'm sure investing
good good good if there's one thing we
know about wade's money it's that it
doesn't jiggle jiggle yeah i want to see
you wiggle wiggle
uh
you made me want a dribble dribble
oh there's a basketball here
there you go dribble all you want riding
in my feet you really gotta see it hmm
i've never driven a fiat six foot two in
a compact
you know that i'm a little bit taller
than that
but that's much shorter than you
anyway
you guys want to hunt some more ghosts
successful yeah yeah
uh we've got all of our sweet equipment
now this time let's try a strategy of uh
sweet equipment and identifying the
ghosts bob you do
bob you did a real good job getting our
equipment in here just wanted to say uh
yeah i contributed i contributed most of
it i i also contributed but nowhere near
as much as you
yeah well
some of us are trying to make this group
successful yeah some of us some of us
some of us some of us i'd say two out of
the three of us really wait are you
getting already up or what oh there you
go yeah
yeah i'm gonna press okay good wait did
you uh make contributions to the pile it
doesn't seem like it
i added one or two small things hardly
even noticeable okay all right
oh we loaded in so fast ooh that was
good
probably because you prepped all those
items bob i really appreciate that yeah
yeah capture a photo of the ghost
cool i could do photo
you want a thermometer
the ghost is dick garcia wow come on man
i'm gonna give whatever this is i don't
even know what this is it's kind of kind
of like a perfume it looks like
that's the dots no it looks like a
perfume bottle well no one ever
explained what the dots did so i don't
even know what it's about put it on the
ground look at the ground and press like
then if the ghost walks through you see
its figure outline because the dots hit
it
but some ghosts you can only see the
dots on camera so if you see it in
person run through you wouldn't notice
ah
oh hey we have the cursed object right
here the mirror again oh
also what the hell is being thrown do
you hear that
oh
well i think we found our ghost where
kitchen
kitchen
oh it's throwing [ __ ] yeah there's cups
on the ground
no no freezing temps in here
[Music]
well
i'm ready to get a picture of it oh did
you get a picture of the cursed mirror
uh no
oh hey bud oh hey bud
no spirit box thus far i'm gonna go grab
the crucifixes
hmm
no handbrake don't worry i'm hustling in
a journal all right thanks bud i don't
see any hand prints probably not that
i'm gonna leave a photo camera just in
here on the floor i got a photo camera
on me so i'll be ready
what if we put some salt down would it
not like that oh that'd be a good idea
oh i'm getting the salt
i'll bring uh smudge i'll smudge
i don't have a lighter i'll run it in
again later i can bring it lighter i can
bring a letter for you ooh cool
what is it what is the candle for
uh
objectives
really like fire so if your candle goes
out it'll hunt and kill you okay cool
all right um
yeah pour some salt right in the
evidence so far we just found out where
it is
i don't know man
good saltine dude
i know dude wait what the hell did i uh
oh hey look did you wait can we make
footprints in the salt wait can we make
it
no ah so we have that
cool
so oh oh i saw footprints i saw glowy
for who did the glowy i just saw glowy
footprints
blowing footprints is probably not a
race because don't leave footprints okay
so is it here in us are you in the room
with us is it here
did it just throw that flashlight
and let me go get it there's something
over here let me go get an infrared
getting an infrared
bob you have camera camera
there's a whole spine in here
oh oh oh gosh goes take a picture take a
picture take a picture
think of it it was in the dots
it was right there in the dots did you
see it guys
why you guys never talk trying to
preserve my life
yeah i was trying not to die for once oh
okay all right did you get a photo of
the bone bob no because i [ __ ] my brains
all right guys
i'm getting a photo now i think it might
it might be one of those harmless ghosts
all right i'm looking from the camera in
the kitchen there i'll keep an eye on it
for you if you need some help you know
oh it's in the room with you it's like
it's like a little scampering ghost
in there yeah it was like a little
scamper
yeah but to be perfectly honest we're
not getting many signs at all there's no
freedom freezing temperature in there no
ghost orbs on the camera
what about the audio thing the the
microphone
i'm bringing it in
the microphone thing i don't know what
it is
it's a sound sensor it'll show you if
there's like sound in a room
where where are you
wait a door just move which door move
i don't know they were both open oh
detecting a lot of sound in that room
[Music]
was that a confirmed uh fingerprint
yes
excellent all right so we have
fingerprints and dots
gorio banshee or phantom
so it's going to be spirit box
so it wasn't singing so that's
definitely not a
be a banshee emf5 which we haven't
gotten yet yeah oh when agorio passes
through dodge protector using a video
camera is the only way to see it so
technically emf 5 would be the thing
and we've not seen it in person but you
said you saw the camera so it probably
is a gloriou well also it says agorio
will usually only show itself on camera
if there are no other people nearby you
were there and it was showing itself all
the time so either spirit box or emf5
we've been trying
i'm gonna go in there because we need to
get our sanity down so i'm gonna i'm
gonna unsanitize
are you taking a [ __ ] right now
if so
what do you want
em f3 for a second
literally only in that spot
maybe it's getting a snack out of the
fridge it might be it might be
it did just use the bathroom maybe it
washed his hands now trying to get some
food yeah i think you're right i think
you're right
richard
give us an emf richard
what was the other one though it was emf
for uh spirit box right do we have a
spare bucks in here yeah we do yeah wade
was using that let me try i'll ask
better questions
orbs be the other thing but you said you
don't think it's a banshee that's
probably not a word i didn't see orbs on
the camera so uh wha what do we have in
here
what's your turn ons
how are you
what's your name can you hear us
how did you die
[Music]
all right nothing on the spirit box so
there's gotta be something else
hmm
yeah oh wait maybe ghost or yes yes i
could only see it from the outside
camera
i think ghost orb i think yes go storm
all right well time to leave then we got
our stuff let's get out of here all
right
did you guys get a photo of it
no
no
all right
i'll tell you when it shows up and you
snow hey oh hi
uh you what i'll do i'll do it i'll do
it i never live anyway all right cool
all right you just stay right in that in
the corner
uh like where the stove is and you point
towards the doorway i'll tell you when
to snap
the thing is we don't know which one of
us is targeting right now so it might be
more likely to show up for one of us
versus the other that's ridiculous yeah
of course my bad
all right bob how you feeling mark tell
me what to do oh don't worry yeah
something's gonna happen uh say its name
richard garcia richard garcia
no he's moving [ __ ] around in front of
me yeah i don't see him on camera though
richard garcia
i heard you're a real piece of trash
ghost
activities up at two it's not very high
i wonder if you're the target mark
you're an idiot you don't even know how
to sing
uh
i might bring in a motion detector so
that you can know when it crosses that
doorway
all right here i'm gonna put
i'm gonna put this i'm gonna put this
right here and if you see that go off
snap it you you need another camera you
need a snack no i'm good i'm guys
richard say it like out loud or
something i don't know i'll come back in
case i'm the target
all right i'll let you know if i see it
oh no no
did you get it
no
yeah it didn't count however it's eaten
half of each crucifix so it's gonna be
able to hunt and murder
oh
activities going up ooh ooh take a
picture it's getting all staticky
hello
you got it you got it yes you got it get
out of there go get out of there guys
get out of there
you did it
you
did it
holy [ __ ] that's
the spooky thing that it does when it
starts singing and flashing everything
uh-huh jesus
yeah it hadn't sung before so one
percent of sanity well job well done
guys job well done
yeah that was a great we got everything
let's get out of here yeah let's go
winners yeah well done bob
i lost hell yeah
yeah i survived one yeah my first time i
lived you are the anchor of this team we
all know it welcome back bob you're like
yeah
i am the anchor of this team both in
that i hold us back when we want to go
forward
and in that i keep us grounded and
sometimes am necessary these are cool
pics man these are cool pics sweet ass
pictures right
hey bob wade did you know that we do a
podcast what i've heard that yeah
i've actually been capturing all the
audio when we have conversations you
know when we're just hanging out and
i've been editing it and i've been
uploading it to various podcasting sites
under the guise of a podcast it's been a
lot of work to try to make it seem like
a cohesive idea but i don't know how
much longer i can actually keep up the
illusion
all
all of our conversations every one of
them yeah
some of that has been pretty
private i know
yeah it would be incredibly embarrassing
for people to hear the things i've heard
i mean all the microphones that i placed
in your bathrooms like
the things you say
uh good content good content those are
for me and an unsuspecting molly only
yeah
yeah and me too i was shocked i was
stunned but it's just a lot of work to
edit all that together i'm thinking i'm
just going to upload it unedited
uh
anyway the podcast is doing great people
really love it but man just this
workload
where is where can i listen to this oh
i'll link it in the description anyone
can listen to it i'm surprised you
haven't heard it yet um oh
yeah man yeah well i don't want to be
one of the people that doesn't listen to
it because that's not the group you want
to be a part of no me too me neither no
they're also i want to be in the cool
group yeah so what you were just like
doing a bit in the bathroom about those
bodies right
you know the chopping people up
yeah no i just i i
i
said yeah
it's an improv
game and it was all
just in my
memory really realistic i'm like your
acting ability is getting really good
the screams from the other from you i'm
guessing actually now yeah all me yeah
yeah yeah yeah is that the clip you sent
over to me yeah is this the one you're
talking about let me play right now here
[ __ ] i can't believe it happened again i
said it this guy this this this is the
last time this cannot happen again
i am running out of yard no it's no
one's gonna look no one's gonna look no
one's gonna look it's fine who would
suspect me
who would suspect me
you know that's why i'm the nice one
that's why
that's why i built this
persona that's why
that's why no one's gonna find out about
this yeah that
that sounds like the right clip yeah
funny right it was laughing
i know it's it's a it's a thinker yeah
but it's just a it's just a joke that's
not
deal anyway i've linked this all in the
description but really guys i need some
help on this uh because i've got a
mountain of clips like this i mean bob
have you heard this one from wade it's
somebody here
hey mr ducky do you want to kiss elmo
where
there i don't want to kiss the dog oh
you're going to kiss you two are going
to smooch you love it so much oh mr
ducky and elmo you're going to have all
the sex and it's going to be so great
yeah is that a bit dude
i don't think that's my voice i think
someone else did that
oh don't even sound like me well it was
in your bathroom so you might want to
check um
because that's that's what you had
a contractor in the house remember the
whole drowned man thing yeah people
ended up all the time yeah by one of
them
yeah but uh
maybe there's some clips of you out
there marking on i'm gonna look through
and find your file folder here bob bob
do you have any files of mark i know i
don't have anything
well you know
uh whatever we do fine just upload it
and help me edit it because this podcast
that's linked in the description that
everybody listening this should hear
is uh real good real scary sometimes uh
but hilarious hilarious to hear these
things
[Music]
i'm glad that you did that okay good
yeah
those bits really make me want to listen
to the book
people watching this did you know we
have a podcast you guys remember the
boner cast don't you want to relive the
glory days
it back baby we revived the boner cast
and all of the glory that that thing
that existed used to have is now
encapsulated in a new podcast called
distractible hundred percent thousand
percent actually links in the
description all the hilarity that you
remember from the bonercast is there do
you miss drunk minecraft good it's dead
but distractible is it so come listen
you remember when we used to play prop
hunt
that's not coming back but you can hear
us together on distractible it's like
without the pretext absolutely did you
like heist with markiplier in space
markiplier parts one and two date with
markiplier are you looking for more
darkiplier and damien and workstash
content well that's not on our podcast
either but we are so come listen to
distract
guys actually i'm thinking that the real
dark applier easter egg is through the
link in the description below i i've
heard rumors that if you look at it and
squint your eyes the link turns like red
and blue
it's pretty cool
and everything around you starts
glitching out getting all dark applied
sure that's not just the police showing
up after all the things we've confessed
to red and blue could also be darkiplier
always if you see behind you when you're
driving down the highway red and blue
flashing lights it's drawn player it
means he's chasing you
you're gonna floor it and get out of
there
it means you gotta go
[Laughter]
he might look like a couple of uniformed
police officers in a well-lit clearly
labeled police car
but it's really dark a place don't do
that for legal reasons we should
probably be really clear that that's a
joke
don't
don't
it's probably not him at all
i love your lack of faith someone's
going to be in court like oh man that 10
car pile up from the chase
i thought it was dark
your honor and like the the judge is a
fan of mine this is 10 years in the
future it's like you really
laugh but when they're playing the
recording of this in court when we get
to this part what's up judge and jerry
uh they're all gonna be like whoa that
was very thoughtful of bob to put such a
clear and unmistakable disclaimer on
such a funny message that no one could
mistake but maybe one person my mistake
as a an actual suggestion i hope they
have video not just audio because i
waved when you said hi judge and jury
and didn't say anything out loud so i'll
do your job for you jury foreman not
guilty
i'm probably not supposed to do that
that's probably illegal but bob you
better cover your ass again while you do
that link in the description to uh our
podcast where dark blur is hiding i just
want to put a disclaimer on the
disclaimer jury for me you don't have to
do what i said you're supposed to be
autonomous unbiased and give a fair
trials to this person you were supposed
to be a jury of their peers ignore
anything i told you to do that would be
jury tampering wow yeah
but i'll do your job for you again when
i'm tried for jury tampering
not guilty
[Music]
you